من بدايه الحرب على غزه يعني من 65 يوم
رفضنا انه احنا نتوجه للجنوب لانه احنا
فاهمين انه العدو هذا عدو جبان وبيخدعك
ظلينا متمسكين وموجودين في غزه نجينا من
مليون استهداف واستهداف كان مباشر للمباني
المجاوره من دون تحذير ولا ولا تنبيه ولا
اي حاجه البنت هذه كان عمرها اسبوع تعرضت
لاصابه في الراس ما لقينا اسعاف ياخذها
الان وانا كمان قصبت واولادي كمان تضرروا
يعني رحنا نزحنا من مكان لمكان من مكان
لمكان من مكان لمكان لما الاخر كنا في
الشجاعيه والان تم محاصره الشجاعيه
واستهداف الناس الامنين فيها افي خاي ادرع
نزل على صفحته كتب توجهه الى الغرب ذهبنا
الى الغرب فتفاجئ بقوات
الاحتلال بتدا المنازل وبتفتش وبترو
الاطفال وبتعتبر وبتبهدل النساء وتركتنا
نخرج بثمان اطفال احنا ومجموعه من النساء
لحالنا في شوارع مدمره بالكامل مالهاش اي
معالم في في الليل في ظل القصر
واطلاق النار والدبابات والدمار والجحيم
ابني التعطر في الارض كان ب يوقع في بير
الله اللي لطفيه لكن هذا الصمت المطبق صمت
العالم امام هذه المجازر كلياتها امام هذا
الجوع والعطش للاطفال امام ترويع الناس
امام ترويع النساء وين نروح وين نروح
ومصير اللي بيعتقل يعتقلهم الاحتلال وين
مصيرهم